So in the spoon 54 Baker take to a market
And rolling curious curious curious and action
Right now
Lost
Have been every voice ever heard inside
Maybe forever
The horse brought together
Oh
a
Few things and then we'll start saying alright, you know, you just you know, I only do didn't know you I
Don't know. What is the one I mean, I guess I'll see when I'm what is it?
Like is it actually connected to some issue just hold anything?
Okay, and it's funny. It's very continuing
What are they
Exactly you're in the middle of it or whatever and then and we sort of catch you in it and we get it
And then at the end
If you just just tighten the line up a little bit
Coming up close
It is gays. Will you come forward just a hair please Oh better. Thank you
Some was it means family
The emotion of it all
Making a film with people that you really love
And this is the last one like it's crazy we do nursery pill taking one last look
as my friend
The feeling onset is one of joy
I've really liked with this film that we get a lot more safe together, especially myself Oscar and Daisy
the dynamic between us three is
Capturing some of that spirit of the original salami it feels like kids going on an adventure
right
And then it was fun too because I hadn't properly worked with Oscar before and he and John
Here Larry. Yes. That's my boy. Hey, we could be a bit cheeky sometimes
As long as he's right next to me I could do anything
The Star Wars universe has created friendships that have lasted for 40 plus years
Fallen deeply deeply led with his men sort of capture that spirit and bring it to a conclusion
Has been such an amazing task felt nice to stand there with Daisy and Austar kind of like, whoa
Wow, that this is truly the end of our contribution to dishonor
But the legacy will carry on
You